alemania se despide de merkel para darle
la bienvenida al nuevo canciller olaf
scholz y luego de que los liberales
ecologistas y también los
socialdemócratas firmaran el acuerdo de
coalición para poder gobernar el país
soulés que obtuvo el respaldo de
395 parlamentarios frente a 300 o 3 en
contra y 6 abstenciones ya curó el cargo
su alianza con los verdes y también los
liberales suman el bundestag
416 escaños del total de 736 el nuevo
canciller si usted en el cargo a la
conservadora angela merkel que traspasa
el poder luego de 16 años a quien fuera
su vice canciller y ministro de finanzas
de su última gran coalición y para ello
entonces quiero saludar a cristina beer
que tanja de politólogo y directora de
la fundación política socialdemócrata
alemana gracias entonces por estar con
nosotros en directo américa de france 24
cristina le pregunto por la composición
de este nuevo gobierno raro en alemania
va a tener ya entonces la facilidad para
gobernar pero entonces le pregunto cómo
va a quedar
de la canciller de la ex canciller
angela merkel va a ser parte de la
oposición
muy buenos días muchas gracias por la
invitación si he hecho el partido de
angela merkel es de oposición ahora ella
misma no forma parte del mundo estar
añadimos un gesto muy interesante esta
mañana ella debía estar en la tribuna de
los espectadores y se subió el
presidente de partido social-demócrata
para agradecerle los sus 16 años de
churchill era de alemania su partido va
a estar en oposición sin ella en este
momento están aclarando se nuevas
cúpulas dentro del partido seguramente
habrá discusiones programáticas como
entre éste y ahora pues me quedé que no
es la más fácil para el partido
conservador alemán cristina eso le
quería hablar entonces cuáles son los
desafíos que tiene este nuevo canciller
o las o la afa sol como recibe a
alemania de angela merkel luego de 16
años y después hablemos del legado pero
primero hablemos de los desafíos del sol
los diseños son enormes porque se
destacaron sobre todo también en
pandemia muchos problemas estructurales
que crecieron durante los últimos 16
años
y esta coalición que se llama una
coalición de progreso realmente quiere
hacer un plan hacia el futuro a
enfrentar estos desafíos que son como ya
se nominó la transición social y
ecológica
a través de energías renovables para
hacer hacia alemania esta fuerza
económica pero sostenible para el futuro
hay desafíos sociales porque ha crecido
también en alemania la desigualdad cada
5 el niño crece en pobreza en este
momento eso quiere acabar el nuevo
gobierno
inmediatamente también hay desafíos en
la digitalización y la modernización del
estado
hay mucho que hacer
facilita algunos procesos internos pero
sobre todo utilizar las posibilidades
positivas que tiene la digitalización
y al final también este gobierno ha
planteado
será una brecha entre lo rural las
ciudades y creo que esta actualización
de semáforo y ver el progreso en lo
digital lo ecológico pero sobre todo en
lo social ahora sí hablemos entonces
delegado estos 16 años que deja el día
de hoy la que fue canciller por todo ese
periodo angela merkel una persona además
muy querida
es verdad ella es una de las políticas
más populares que ha tenido alemania
hasta ahora y su legado es innegable y
creo que alemania es bastante agradecido
a este liderazgo de ella que siempre ha
sido conservadora sobre todo en política
y ella ha establecido una imagen de
alemania como mediadora como buscando a
rebasar los crisis los tantos crisis que
ha manejado esta chatarra pero hay que
decir también que ha sido un legado de
una que antes era conservadora porque
hay una media que es del partido
conservador muy concentrado en el
estatus y eso para mí también es la
explicación que queremos a los desafíos
esto en lo estructural ahora en alemán
por eso también el gobierno ahora y sus
grandes enormes
investigaciones
para realmente ver y fortalecer la
fuerza que en la alemania para que pueda
asumir este día liderazgo que alguien la
merca de cierta manera preparó pero que
ahora realmente hay que asumir para
enfrentar no sólo los problemas internas
de alemania pero los enormes desafíos
que tenemos
a la escala global los problemas
globales que alemania que tener ayuda
resolviendo y precisamente hablamos
también del poderío y el liderazgo de
alemania dentro de la unión europea la
principal economía de la unión europea
como queda entonces alemania ahora al
frente de olaf scholz mantendrá su
poderío mantendrá su liderazgo también
teniendo en cuenta que ella francia pasa
a ser el presidente de la unión europea
por el primer semestre de 2022
sí estoy muy convencida que con el plan
que ahora tiene el gobierno el plan este
de fortalecer el liderazgo pero de la
manera cooperativa como siempre ha sido
creo que él ha absuelto ahora tiene
también el chance de
seguir con las buenas relaciones que ha
tenido angela merkel con ansia quizás
intensifica les depende también un poco
de cómo salen las elecciones francesas
ciertamente como decía usted en perú
creo que alemania realmente quiere
asumir un liderazgo quiere ser como un
ejemplo con su transformación social
ecológica justa quiere asegurar que
también dentro de la unión europea se
hace de una manera
socialmente justa y
por ejemplo con muchos nuevos empleos
dentro de la unión europea y eso creo
que son hacen los nuevos que seguramente
hay que mirar también a esta muy fuerte
ya en sus pronunciamientos
contra enemigos de la democracia y
fortaleciendo la democracia interna por
ejemplo tener mucho más
representatividad este gobierno que los
de antes entonces allí veo que hay un
una promesa para estar aún más fuerte en
defender la democracia que es algo muy
importante en estos días pues cristina
muchísimas gracias entonces por analizar
y comprender un poco lo que pasa en
alemania luego de esta era de 16 años de
poderío de la canciller angela merkel y
ahora con este nuevo canciller hola